question 4
qu'est ce que tu veux dire donc tu sais
tu comment s'appelle ce genre de gâteau
non une langue de chat
jacques whitacre a dit noam le pourquoi
mais pourquoi donc les manchots
donne-t-il un caillou à lormont shot
pense que toute une histoire il s'agit
du manchot de la terre adélice d'un
manchon français j'avais la terre adélie
c'est dans la banlieue du pôle chine un
morceau de terre qui appartient à la
france qui fait le manchot de la tirade
hadjithomas robien qui loue un petit
manchot autres 45 cm comme ça vous savez
qui suis adroit sur ses pattes comme un
pingouin gilet blanc jacques et noir
petite calotte noire bec pointu quand
ils marchent les tenants d'une façon un
peu ridicule d'ailleurs quand il veut
couché sur la glace à toute allure il se
couche par terre et avec ses ailes qui
sont devenus des ailerons je vais le
manchot est un pingouin dont les ailes
sont atrophiés soit plus que les
ailerons il rame rame rame rame et
défilent à toute allure et puis cette
année motif le monde bouge ton émotif
dès qu'il ya quelque chose qui
l'impressionnent qui veut exprimer
quelque chose d'important alors c'est la
cérémonie alors le manchot s'immobilise
tête en l'air bête vers le ciel les
ailerons s'agiter iran écrit comme un
âne alors ça c'est la grosse cérémonie
la grosse ex casa grosse émotion à part
ça un merveilleux nageurs qui nagent
mieux qu'un poisson et tout l'hiver
austral c'est à dire notre était à nous
puisque les saisons sont à l'envers
là-bas tout l'hiver austral il est allé
les manches aux années mais
individuellement sans copains tout seul
chacun de leur côté à travers l'océan
pacifique où ils se sont gavés de
boissons bio manger manger moins ce qui
fait que en septembre quand ils
reviennent sains à terre adélie sont
gros comme des chanoines sont super ils
arrivent tranquillement sur la terre
adélie débarquent ils montent sur le sol
il se met à marcher quand il ya de la
place inglis et enfin il arrive à
l'endroit où ils veulent et sont
retrouvés c'est là l'endroit où il était
né une sorte de grandes plaines où est
le rassemblement des manchots alors là
vous avez un spectacle extrêmement 15-20
millions show à la fois qu'ils sont là
tous ensemble izba il aurait ya un
problème pour le manchot de vous
retrouver sa manche hot de l'année
dernière c'est avec qui il a pondu élus
et des petits et pour la manche se
retrouver sur man show oublier cette
foule rien ne ressemble à un match comme
un autre comme on fait alors ils se
promènent tazi curieux à voir il se
promène comme ça la tête en bas écrit il
me faut s qui crient leur nom ici j'ai
tout écrit le nom de la petite copine
wattu joly on se parle mais
l'extraordinaire c'est qu'ils finissent
par se retrouver parce que leurs
faisceaux tout petit peu différents les
uns des autres alors ils se retrouvent
ya six voies qui sont produits alors
vous pensez la cérémonie le manchot et
la manchote en face de l'autre tête en
l'air bête d'elle le chien et loup ont
agité les cris henry en bray comme un
âne part lundi moment ils sont très
contents il se retrouve bon quelques
jours après la manchote à c e et c'est
là le point important qui apportera des
explications à la question que ma
position rixe est c'est eux il va
répondre dans le nid des manchots qu'il
ya un truc assez extraordinaire c'est un
simple petit rond de cailloux par terre
au milieu de laquelle madame manchots
s'allonge ton c'est le zew et elle va
les couver des jours pendant lesquels
sont en revanche sont fautives pas ça va
aller à l'océan pour se ravitailler il
va à l'océan pour se ravitailler il
revient il retrouve sa petite copine
tête afin de combler la cérémonie de
reconnaissance tête en l'air vers le
ciel un gros agitée et on retouche
jacques extase il prend sa place il se
met sur les usa place il va nous prouver
encore quinze jours elle pendant ce
temps-là est allé à l'océan pour se
ravitailler pour manger bâtiment je
reviens je suis qui courent il revient
et il retrouve son petit copain en train
de couver les oeufs ses amis
reconnaissance tête vers le ciel paix
quand l'air est trop agitée qui en iran
elle prend sa place sur les oeufs et les
couvre lui retourne de saison pour se
ravitailler il revient six jours après
ils sont là c'est le gros événement les
oeufs ont éclos et les petits sont là
cachées sous la mer ce qui fait quand
même moins 20 pour se tenir au chaud
alors ils regardent les deux manchots se
lève regarde les petits alors là au
bourget des demandes est décédé dimanche
l'un qui gagnent de netbook se fout tête
en l'air bête vers le ciel elles ont
agité et en riant on n'avait jamais vu
de si beaux petits manchots dans mon
livre des merveilles et ça ça braie
pendant un quart d'heure puis ils vont
là dessus nourrir leurs petits tous
ensemble les deux ensemble ils vont
jusqu'au moment où les petits seront
capables d'aller pêcher tout seul
r là dans la mer et toutes les fois
qu'ils reviennent cérémonie peut-être en
herbe éclairent le ciel elles ont agité
en iran parce que tout à des superbes la
la la bande des manchots est absolument
enthousiastes ça c'est vrai pour les
manches où ils sont mariés qui avaient
déjà une tes copines l'année dernière
avec qui ils ont eu d eux qu elle a
pondu qu'ils ont couvé ensemble qu'ils
ont d'autres sont élevés les petits
ensembles mais les manchots célibataire
ce qui est bâti deux copines il faut
qu'il se trouve une petite copine alors
il cherche une petite mouche qui lui
plaît bien ils s'installent de watten et
la cérémonie tête en l'air bien le ciel
droit gti en iran et si la fille lui
plaît bien et qui voit qu'il lui plaît
il ramasse un caillou par terre et il le
lui donne il lemercier innovants tel est
la manchette ramasse cailloux et celle
enthousiasme les vraiment les ailerons
agité pourquoi parce que ce caillou un
sens qui signifie je sais que quand tu
couvres ade sera au milieu d'un rond de
cayouche qu'apporte le premier tu vois
comme je serai un bon mari et leur
argent nourrice qui fait que le cadeau
de noces sur la terre adélie un caillou
et voilà pourquoi le manchot d'un
caillou ça marche même si on faisait ça
nous serait clair y'a pas de problème
c'est qu'il donne des cailloux à
quelqu'un c'est bon